[موسيقى]
في مدينه خرسون جنوب اوكرانيا لا يتوقف
صوت نيران المدفعيه الروسيه في اكتوبر
تشرين الاول الماضي وقبل الانسحاب الروسي
منخرسون قامت القوات الروسيه باجلاء
المدنيين من المدينه ومن بين هؤلاء مئات
الاطفال
ناتاليا شهده على ما تسميه باختطاف
الاطفال الاوكرانيين
جاءت حافلات بيضاء وتوقفت امام البوابه
قاموا بتطويق المحيط بعربته بالمدرعه ولم
يسمح لاحد بالاقتراب اتذكر ايضا انهم
قاموا بتفتيش الهواتف المحموله حتى لا يتم
تصويرهم اصبنا جميعا بالذعر والصدمه لكن
ما باليد حيله لقد قاموا باختطاف الاطفال
من دار الايتام
في الحادي والعشرين من اكتوبر تشرين الاول
وصف نائب رئيس بلديه خيرسون الموالي
لروسيا ترحيل الاطفال بانقاذهم من القصف
المدفعي لقد انقذنا هؤلاء الاطفال انهم في
امان مديره دار الايتام معهم الان كل شيء
سيكون على ما يرام صدقوني هدفنا هو انقاذ
الارواح والتفكير في مستقبل اطفالنا
تاكدنا من ان القوات الروسيه طردت مديره
دار الايتام واستبدالتها باخرى مواليه
لموسكو استطعنا فيما بعد التواصل معها
هاتفيا
رفضت التعاون معهم لقد عرضوا علي عده مرات
ان اعمل معهم بعدها تاكدوا انني ساعيق
مخططهم لذا طردوني
بعض هؤلاء الاطفال عثرنا عليهم في هذه
الصوره مع مسؤوله حقوق الاطفال الروسيه
ماريا
منذ الغزو الروسي لاوكرانيا ضاعفت ماريا
الفوفا فيلوفا مقاطع الفيديو الدعائي على
صفحتها
تظهر هذه المره وهي تنقل بعض الاطفال
اليتامى الاوكرانيين الى الاسر الروسيه
التي ستكفلهم
تم قصف جميع المستشفيات كما تشاهدون قذيفه
اصابت تلك النافذه اما النوافذ الاخرى
فتحطمت بسبب شظايا صاروخ اخر سقط قرب
المستشفى يخاطر طاقم الطبي في مستشفى
خرسون يوميا بسبب القصف
هنا سقطت قذيفه اخرى لقد دخلت من النافذه
وحطمت ذلك الجدار حدث هذا في ليله راس
السنه ثم تبعتها سبعه صواريخ تم قصف
المستشفى ثلاث مرات مع هذا نواصل العمل
لانه ليس لدينا خيار اخر الاطفال بحاجه
الينا
قام هؤلاء الاطباء بمجازفه كبيره من قبل
وهناك
كان في هذا القسم المهجور اخفوا عشره
ايتام من القوات الروسيه
هنا قمنا بتركيب اسره وسخانات اضافيه في
الجهه المقابله كنا نعد لهم
تقول انه في كل صباح كانت القياده الروسيه
تطلب من المستشفيات تزويدها بقوائم
الاطفال الذين يمكن نقلهم الى موسكو لذا
قاموا بتزوير بعض الوثائق ووضعوا اجهزه
تنفس بالقرب من الاسره للادعاء بان
الاطفال مرضى ولا يمكن نقلهم في هذه
الحاله بالطبع كنا خائفين كانت مخاطره
كبيره للغايه بالنسبه لكل الموظفين في
المستشفى لكن كلا منا كان يدافع عن
اوكرانيا بطريقته ونحن هذه طريقهنا في
الدفاع عن بلدنا
امه عاديه لا تاتي اليك بالدبابات
والاطفال مهمون بالنسبه لكل الامم لذا
بالطبع يجب على الجميع فعل كل شيء للدفاع
عنهم قام مدير المدرسه الداخليه للايتام
ورعايه الطفوله باخفاء اطفال المركز عند
بعض العائلات وفي منازل الموظفين قبل وصول
الجنود الروسي اليه
حيث ننظم الفعاليات الموسيقيه ونحتفل
بالعام الجديد وهذه صور لاطفالنا الاثنين
والخمسين الذين تمكنا من اخفائهم خلال
فتره احتلال خاصه
كيف اخذوا الاطفال من هناك ونعرف ايضا
تاريخ الاتحاد السوفيتي
من غرب اوكرانيا الى سيبيريا لهذا السبب
كنا نخشى من نفس المصير
الماضي جاءت القوات الروسيه الى فلوديف
لاول مره
ها هي سيارتهم قدموا مع ناصر من اف اس بي
اول سؤال طرحوه علي كان انهم الاطفال
كانوا يسالون دائما عن مكان وجودهم اخبرنا
اين الاطفال
ولحسن حظه انهم صدقوه بعدها بشهر احضروا
له 15 طفلا يتيما وقالوا انهم اجلوهم من
احد الملاجئ التي كانت على خط المواجهه
الاطفال جلبوهم الينا في عربات عسكريه
كانوا قلقين جدا ظنوا انهم سينقلون الى
روسيا عاشوا معنا لمده ثلاثه اشهر ثم في
التاسع عشر من اكتوبر تشرين الاول عندما
انسحب الروس منخرسون اخذوا الاطفال معاهم
لم يكن لدينا خيار اخر قلت لهم ارجوكم
عودوا لهم غدا عليهم ان يستعدوا فهم ليسوا
جنودا انهم مجرد اطفال قالوا لي نعطيك
ساعتين
اذا ق فسناتي بمزيد من الجنود لاخدهم
بمساعده المنظمات غير الحكوميه الدوليه
تمكن بعض الاطفال اخيرا من العوده الى
اهاليهم حيث تشير ارقام كييف الى استرجاع
300 طفل من اصل 16 الف ومئتين تم ترحيلهم
الى موسكو وفي ظل استمرار الحرب من الصعب
جدا حاليا احصاء عدد الاطفال الذين رحلوا
بموافقه اوليائهم او الذين تم اختطافهم
مثل ما تقولوا السلطات الاوكرانيه